and before I could think anymore the
Moose was like who's this freaky big
eared chinless freak standing on my
grassy knoll and he charged straight at
me
charged me welcome to this is not
happening I'm rolling with junior when
traveling late
[Music]
the Harlan Highway this is parlance
well I shouldn't even be here gang I
shouldn't even be alive yours truly has
had a few pretty dangerous encounters
with wildlife well if you want to laugh
that I'm almost dad
but I had three encounters three
encounters with nature way back in the
day I used to be a forest ranger and I'm
up in northern Canada I'm driving around
in my pickup truck I got a 3/4 ton
pickup truck hey and I'm driving around
I'm going down an old lumber Road an old
dirt lumber oh and I'm just driving
along having thoughts in my head about
you know oatmeal and psoriasis and
things like that
but I'm driving along and all of a
sudden I see this big mound of grass and
I slam on the brakes I'm like but it
wasn't like a screeching tire sound
because I was on gravel I just told you
that gang it was more like a so I
stopped my my 3/4 ton pickup truck Hey
and I look on the top of this grassy
knoll and there's a full-grown moose
there's a moose standing on a grassy
knoll and I'm thinking ok there's a
moose here's me I'm gonna see how close
I can get to the moose right so he's
pulling the grass he's like then he's
chewing he's like you know it's like
watching a fat family from Ohio go
through a lasagna bar at Golden Corral
right
and I'm thinking if I imitate these
sounds I'll get close to the Moose I
start pulling the grass I pull chew and
I keep getting closer and closer and
closer then I'm about 20 feet from this
full-grown moose and I'm thinking wait a
minute
what's my endgame here you want to get
up to this moose and scratch it behind
the ears don't want to rub its hump do I
want to play with that hairy nut bag
that dangles under its chin
you know just fiddle with its throat bag
and before I could think any more the
Moose was like who's this freaky big
eared chinless freak standing on my
grassy knoll and he charged right at me
charge me and at the last second just
before he's about to hit me there was a
dead tree hanging over the grassy knoll
he hit it
the tree shattered and he got spooked
and went the other way now the upside is
I peed my pants
I wanted the grass so there you go now
let's smash cut to Rwanda hello
we're looking for the legendary mountain
gorillas you know the ones that Dian
Fossey saw in the mist but it was really
like her bong smoke right and now we're
climbing up this volcano and boom we
come across the mountain gorilla the
mother and the children and the auntie's
but where's the big boy
huh they told me there was a 500-pound
silverback gorilla there in the mountain
right I'm like where's the big boy and
all of a sudden we hear it it's like
[Applause]
there he is
500-pound silverback opens the bamboo
right just peels it open presents
himself postures right slides down right
in front of us just stand-in there with
his big eyebrows just staring at
all of us and I'm thinking this is great
till I realized in our group of eight
people I'm the only guy with a brand-new
bright shiny red baseball hat and so now
two Spanish words are going through my
head Olay Olay and sure enough just as I
finish that thought I heard our guide go
he's attacking here comes this giant
500-pound silverback gorilla just
charging at me he's beating his chest
he's he just hitting his Aereo lies so
hard I thought they're gonna fly off and
land on my eyes right here he comes with
these mount gorillas they do a thing
called a mock charge it's to show
dominance so he wasn't really gonna hit
me but he came closer to the most he
came like four feet in front of me and
then went the other way
and of course at that point I once again
produce something in my pants it was a
he's a Cracker Barrel meatloaf and
lastly let's smash cut to the Pacific
Ocean sir if you could look away sir
your focus is scary I'm fishing the
Pacific Ocean gang going for salmon you
ever catch a salmon my love ah when
you're not busy rolling around in the
hazelnut fields fishing I'm out in a
17-foot boat fishing for salmon right I
got a bait boy with me this guy's like a
college kid he's like Spicoli from Fast
Times at Ridgemont I just a STONER dude
I'm pretty sure when I wasn't looking he
was smoking the bait right then we're
out there fishing and the oceans nice
and calm and I look about 50 yards away
and all this and I see this circle of
bubbles on the surface of the water big
circle of bubbles and what the hell is
that and then all of a sudden two giant
humpback whales just exploded from under
the water their mouths open they
swallowed a whole school of fish and I
was like what the hell was that stoner
bro he's like oh he's like the
humpback whales that's how they hunt man
they go down to the bottom of the ocean
they look for a school of fish and then
they blow bubbles out of the asshole on
their head right so they swim around the
school of fish and they create a wall of
bubbles and then they come up and they
swallow the whole school of fish the
fish in the wall of bubbles are afraid
to go through so they get trapped right
I don't thinking would that be funny if
I could get those whales to come over
here and I could get a nice little
picture of the wind
so of course I start doing some whale
calls to attract the rider life
[Music]
nothing so I go back to fishing and a
few minutes later holy I look
beside me a bubble comes up right beside
the boat just one bubble right there's
probably like a sea cucumber fart coming
up to the head so I'm like there's a
bubble and then suddenly there's another
bubble and another one and another one
and all sudden I realized hold there
doing a bubble circle right under the
damn bow I'm like what then and all of a
sudden I put the boat in reverse I pull
that sucker backwards and I swear to god
just as I get out of the bubble circle
three feet off the front of the boat two
giant
humpback whales these things are 60 feet
long the length of three Greyhound buses
mouths open tons of fish going down and
I'm like holy that could have been
us and the stoner dude was like yeah
[Applause]